are you guys hey everybody let's freak
out over brie Larson's Captain Marvel
costume so obviously this is a version
of the original Captain Marvel costume
the green one from the comics so I'll
try to explain the progression and why
it looks like this why she's walking
around because a lot of people thought
that this was actually a fan edit like
wait a minute
just remember what it looks like when
Aunt May and Robert Downey jr. are
walking around on set and you get the
paparazzi photos how the colors looked
all washed out they tuned that up in
post-production so like the green of her
costume will pop a little bit more on
screen but because we had that big
comic-con panel last year where Kevin
Feige showed off all the footage of her
fighting the Kree fighting the Skrulls
we saw her in the classic red gold blue
obviously shall get that version of the
costume either at the end of Captain
Marvel or either the beginning or the
end of one of the Avengers films because
like the Russo brothers say they may or
may not be introducing new characters
winking from behind the camera like they
can't confirm that they're gonna be
doing Captain Marvel during infinity war
and Avengers 4 but spider-man style
she's supposed to show up briefly during
infinity war at some point maybe in the
post-credits stinger and then she'll be
a much bigger character during Avengers
4 because that's gonna happen after the
Captain Marvel movie this is a clip from
that interview where the Russos sort of
confirmed the Captain Marvel is gonna
appear during infinity war at some point
but they try to talk around it a little
bit and they also talk about the title
reveal for Avengers 4 depicting Carole
damn in theory that would that have been
fun to do it's interesting when you get
to bring it's interesting when you get
to play with characters in this universe
because you are dealing with actors who
have been playing parts for you know
almost a decade yeah and it's
interesting to bring new energy into the
mix especially when you're you know
you're doing this massive mosaic of a
story so you know there will be
surprises of course in these movies we
won't confirm okay third off we want to
confirm or deny but but is certainly
going to be some
curveballs thrown at you well is there a
timeline of when we're gonna even know
the title of the of the next Avengers
film like does that come right out of
the release of infinity war duty at
opera is it is certainly you know part
of the concept of the title is that it's
it's it's it's advancing the narrative
so it's we're gonna sit on that until we
feel the time is right right and when
people have absorbed the first movie so
if there was any confusion everything
that you're seeing with her in the green
costume reading a newspaper like it's no
big deal is for the Captain Marvel movie
it just because I forgot to mention it
at the beginning of the video yeah there
is a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway I'll name a new winner at the
end of the video but there's been a
whole bunch of Captain Marvel movie
stuff happening lately because she's
been practicing with the air force
people literally learning how to fly as
she jokes tongue-in-cheek like yeah
she'll be flying when she's Captain
Marvel because of her powers but she'll
also be flying because she's a captain
in the Air Force which is where the
captain of Captain Marvel comes from
although technically that was inspired
by Captain America like he was the one
that told her in the comics to stop
calling herself Miss Marvel and call
herself Captain Marvel but we're mixing
and matching a bunch of different eras
the green costume was the very first
version that any version of Captain
Marvel ever wore so the first version of
the character dr. Walter Lawson debuted
during the 60s when he was sent to earth
he's this creeper s'en who's sent to
infiltrate earth he's wearing the green
costume he assumes the identity of the
deceased scientist dr. Walter Lawson who
was supposed to be played by Jude Law in
the film he gets into a series of
adventures with the Avengers over the
next 10 to 20 years the kree-skrull war
he almost dies a couple times he helps
the Avengers battle Thanos and take the
Cosmic Cube from him but during the
earlier years they introduced the Miss
Marvel character Carol Danvers and she
got her powers in this accident with
this giant device that jaan raghav
weapon so the thing about the movie is
is they said they were gonna change her
origin story just a little bit so it
didn't feel so much like a Green Lantern
story because it does read kind of like
Green Lantern if you're not a big comic
book person but here's the really cool
Easter Egg so the green costume that
she's wearing doesn't look anything like
the
Captain Marvel costume is just the green
Cree color scheme that's the only thing
that ties it to that what it looks like
though is the modern version of the
costume just a different color if you
pull the current version into Photoshop
and just simply invert the colors what
does it look like it looks like the
version that they showed us in the
concept art so whatever is going to
happen whether she's gonna recolor the
suit or there's gonna be some accident
that makes it look like the modern
version of the costume she's wearing one
of the Kree army uniforms now it could
be Marvel's costume and maybe at some
point during the film he dies and she
just starts wearing it or it could just
be a very common version of a Kree
military uniform because the Ravagers
are a good example of people that wear
the same costumes like Peter quill has
that leather jacket but for the most
part the Ravagers costumes are all
exactly the same it's kind of the same
deal with the Kree army it's just that
we haven't seen other live-action
versions of them yet we've only seen the
concept art so it sounds like they'll
incorporate some of the aspects of the
kree-skrull war and some of her a
classic origin story with young raagh
and dr. Walter Lawson but just expects
some minor changes from the comic books
because the movie is currently filming
right now the other thing that they've
been talking about is Cobie Smulders and
Sam Jackson showing up on set so a lot
of people are like wait a minute Nick
Fury and Maria hill in Avengers 4 okay
that's really cool but the thing is is
they're not shooting Avengers 4 because
the Brousseau said that they already
wrapped like they filmed their last
scenes a little while ago earlier this
month they have started pre-production
on Captain Marvel so I think that's what
we're seeing here like we're seeing the
introduction of Captain Marvel in one of
the Avengers films wherever they decide
to put it it's in present-day because
Nick Fury only has one eye he's supposed
to have two eyes during the Captain
Marvel movie because it's set during the
90s and it's her return to Earth because
like they're looking up at the sky like
holy so this might be connected to
Avengers but I just feel like they're
shooting this for the Captain Marvel
movie so I know there are a lot of
longtime Captain Marvel miss Marvel fans
out there most of you are probably
familiar with the different versions of
her costume I'm sure they'll be jokes
about the classic version but really
like the original version was the bare
midriff then they covered that up she
had the Cape then she went to the SAS
version that she had for a number of
years and the more
modern version also had a sash but more
recently it's become more militaristic
looking when she became captain marble
this one is the binary costume and she
still has the binary ability but this is
when she was like stuck in binary form
she become empowered on a more cosmic
level so when she goes binary it's kind
of like her version of hooking out she
absorbs any kind of energy solar energy
energy weapons and then can redirect it
so sometimes they have really funny
moments where the other Avengers will
shoot her with an energy beam to charge
her up like give me a charge I need some
more power so Iron Man will just blast
her with his arc reactor it'll be fun to
see brie Larson on screen with Robert
Downey jr. because of her military
pedigree she's very good at leading
other people I think you know whatever
happens with the other older a list
Avengers if they transitioned out
eventually she's a good candidate for
one of the future leaders of the
Avengers because I think that someday
spider-man could be that person but
right now he's only about 16 17 years
old so he's not going to be leading any
teams anytime soon I know everyone's
wondering how they're going to use her
powers to help defeat Thanos like what
is it that she does that helps tip the
scales in the other direction because it
sounds like they won't have her during
infinity war the Avengers will either
die or get their asses handed to them
then in Avengers 4 they'll rally they'll
get the help of Captain Marvel and
that'll tip the balance back in their
direction but I think the key is in her
ability to absorb energy in her
experience battling cosmic beings like
this so make all your jokes about how
Thanos has infinite amounts of energy
just imagine him soaking her with one of
the infinity gems if he had the gauntlet
I don't know that she could withstand
that there is a question of power
scaling like how powerful will the
Infinity Gauntlet of the movies be
compared to the comics because like the
odinforce for example they tuned that
down a little bit
technically the odinforce makes Odin one
of the most powerful people in the
universe like I would be willing to
guess the Captain Marvel would be able
to soak Thor's lightning the same way
that Iron Man's armor could that'll
actually be pretty funny like he charges
Iron Man's armor up to a thousand
percent but let me know in the comments
what do you think of the costumes so far
and how do you want that to use her
powers when they fight Thanos
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Erik - vendor please private
message me so I can get your contact
tells I'll name another winner when I
post new Marvel which would be pretty
soon just leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below
but click here for that black panther
superbowl trailer and click here to
learn all about Captain America during
infinity war from the directors thank
you so much for watching everybody stand
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you